we are just under a year away from the
Super Bowl touching down in Las Vegas
turns out local students working with
the host committee to bring it here Ryan
Matthey reports on their efforts
I think we'll be better there up here
yeah inside the UFC Apex these students
are halfway into their new internship
I'm just a small town girl from Oregon
like Marley salvater with a passion for
sports and Communications Instagram
Facebook Twitter Tick Tock just got up
and running and Shane saucita who's a
whiz on social media they're both
getting their graduates degrees here at
UNLV and they're just two of 45 students
helping to bring Las Vegas its first
Super Bowl an internship partnership
between UNLV and the Las Vegas Super
Bowl host committee we come in the
office every morning go to our
respective bosses and assigned various
tasks whether that's clipping media from
our various events attending
familiarization events at Allegiant
Stadium we have a lot of creative
Liberty with some of our smaller
platforms that we're able to just bring
our ideas to our superiors who you or do
you not feel Bonita I feel Bonita
content creating writing event planning
all what 45 students get paid need to do
to support the big games Journey here
well they've never been a fully paid
internship throughout the entire
planning process of a Super Bowl Jay
Vickers is CEO of UNLV sports Innovation
not only is our city changing what fan
engagement looks like what entertainment
means in sports and the best way to
really do that is combine that with the
efforts of higher up higher ed a once in
a lifetime opportunity that's a
touchdown for these interns it's amazing
to see so many women in this building
doing what I want to be doing and it's
really broadened my horizons and opened
my eyes to different positions that I
could hopefully one day be in that's an
experience that you can't you can't just
get that anywhere
United Way also pitched in one hundred
thousand dollars for this program and
this is just the first round of interns
each one's roughly five months long
another two sets come this summer and
fall applications will be open to UNLV
students via the handshake app over on
campus